bonsoir à toutes et tous et bienvenue
sur tv fil 78 si vous nous rejoignez
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
le débat de ce soir porte sur la qui rit
la crise des migrants
il aura suffi d'une photo une seule
celle d'un petit garçon syrien de trois
ans retrouvé mort sur une plage en
turquie pour créer l'émotion en europe
mais vous le savez l'émotion est un
sentiment éphémère qui a laissé place un
vif débat sur la question des migrants
les premiers réfugiés syriens et
irakiens sont arrivés dans les yvelines
dans la ville de beaune elle la semaine
dernière alors que des maires ont
accepté d'accueillir des migrants dans
leurs villes d'autres ont refusé
nous allons donc tenter de comprendre
pourquoi est de savoir si les yvelines
et plus largement la france peuvent dans
un contexte économique difficile
accueillir des réfugiés et surtout leur
offrir un avenir
vous pouvez réagir participer poser
toutes vos questions sur le twitter de
l'émission hashtag 7,8 société quatre
invités autour de la table pour ce débat
alain hajjaj d'abord maire communiste de
la verrière bonsoir bernard de bain mer
les républicains de saint cyr l'école
bonsoir bonsoir pascal rodier secrétaire
départemental du secours populaire
français des événements soit en soi et
enfin un mamadou dème vous êtes
sociologue spécialiste des migrations et
du développement local bonsoir soir
alors alain jason va commencer avec vous
pour votre qu'elle n'y a pas lieu de
s'interroger il est du devoir des
communes d'accueillir les réfugiés
vous l'avez d'ailleurs indiqué dans un
communiqué de presse nous avons le
devoir d'agir
oui c'est une évidence mais cette façon
c'est depuis longtemps juste d'ailleurs
c'est pas la photo de l'enfant sur la
plage qui fait réagir n'a été qu'un
accélérateur ça fait la question de la
crise des migrants et des réfugiés dure
depuis plusieurs mois plusieurs années à
la verrière en une commune qui avons
accueilli beaucoup de migrants et de
réfugiés tout au long de ces dix vingt
trente dernières années
on ne pouvait pas rester insensible ça
veut pas dire que tout ça doit se faire
sans discussion sans débat la question
ne s'arrête pas
est ce que l'on doit accueillir pour moi
c'est évident mais par contre la
question c'est également comment doit-on
accueillir
et puis surtout comment doit-on agir
pour éviter qu'ils aient lu migrants
alors bernard de bain vous avez refusé
d'accueillir des migrants en tout cas
cette année puisque vous en aviez déjà
dans votre ville que vous avez accueilli
l'année dernière lorsque vous pouvez
m'expliquer pourquoi pourquoi ce refus
comme vous dites donc c'est pas cette
année puisque en 2014 nous avons
accueilli des réfugiés iraquiens donc la
vague de réfugiés
elle s'est amplifiée mais elles existent
déjà depuis un an et demi deux ans mon
problème c'est s'est réfugié il faut
s'en occuper c'est pas le tout de leur
trouver un toit
c'est après qu'ils aient ce qui va jo
après jour semaine après semaine
assurer le suivi le suivi tout bête
c'est que les aides
elle n'arrive pas tout de suite il faut
des semaines voire des mois
or vous avez invité un représentant du
secours populaire je tiens à dire que
les associations à saint cyr que soit le
secours populaire le secours catholique
et les restos du coeur se sont mobilisés
il a fallu meubler l'appartement qu'on
mettait à leur disposition
il a fallu aussi depuis 10 mois qu'ils
sont dans la ville leur donner à manger
tous les jours donc ce que vous nous
dites c'est que vous n'êtes pas contre
le fait d'accueillir des réfugiés comme
certains maires républicains l'ont
annoncé dans la presse mais vous c'est
que vous n'avez pas les moyens
aujourd'hui d'accueillir des réfugiés à
sancerre l'école à l'heure actuelle
en tout les camps ce qui concerne la
ville je n'avais pas d'autres logements
dans quelques semaines ils auront tous
non seulement le statut mais des revenus
actuelle ils sont trois en avoir sur
cinq adultes
il y en a le père et la mère de famille
puisque en plus trois enfants derrière
il paraît que le dossier bloqué à la caf
on ne sait pas pourquoi c'est pas
pourquoi donc ils n'ont pas de revenus
et une fois qu'ils ont ça on va pouvoir
les basculer vers le parc social
donc on pourra libérer l'appartement que
l'on a mais et ces gens là pour les
associations et moi je me tourne vers
les associations qui les prennent en
charge qui ont assuré le début des cours
de français qui les ont soutenus qui les
ont aidés dans leurs démarches
s'il y en a plusieurs dizaines ou
dizaine est ce que les associations sont
capables de le faire
alors ça c'est la question qu'on va
poser à pascal rodier est-ce que vous
avez les moyens de le faire ryder
lançait déjà des actions
oui ils appellent aux dons notamment bah
moi je peux pas déjà à prendre la parole
au nom toutes les associations le
secours populaire c'est une association
de solidarité qui existe depuis soixante
dix ans maintenant c'est pas nouveau
qu'il y ait des migrants quelle que soit
la définition qu'on met sur le thème
viennent en france dans des situations
de précarité et besoins pendant un laps
de temps plus ou moins long
la solidarité nationale de solidarité
d'état où la solidarité des associations
ou des particuliers puisque tout ne
passe pas nécessairement par les
associations y aussi des gens généreux
qui peuvent se passer d'associations
pour faire la solidarité faut pas non
plus qu'il faut pas six rien
actuellement vaut pas systématiquement
rentrer dans une logique où
ça sera nécessairement les associations
qui feront le tampon entre la venue de
jean sans droit et l'accès au droit
c'est dire que c'est vrai que maintenant
souvent en ce moment c'est un petit peu
ce qu'on propose comme comme véhicule ou
comme trajectoire pour ceux qui ont la
chance d'arriver dans des pays qui ne
sont pas en guerre en tout cas pour si
on parle des migrants pour raison de
conflits armés migrants inconnu
économique c'est un autre sujet bien sûr
que nous n'avons pas à l'heure actuelle
la capacité financière et humaine de
prendre en charge de l'alphabétisation
de beaucoup de migrants c'est à dire que
là nous sur la ville de trappes on a
trois ateliers de sl on appelle ça de
l'atelier social accusations devant
steve français sont des gens parfois qui
habite en france depuis un certain
nombre d'années et qui déjà ne
maîtrisent pas suffisamment bien le
français pour pouvoir avoir accès à un
emploi une vie sociale équilibrés tout
ça donc baladant les migrants il ya le
travail de l'ofpra qui va se faire aussi
donc il faut laisser le temps aux
agences de produire leur travail tandis
laisser le temps c'est à dire combien de
temps voilà j'ai envie de vous dire que
ça va dépendre de la volonté politique
combat derrière c'est à dire que selon
les cas ça peut aller très vite mais on
sait maintenant que le pour le statut de
réfugié politique la durée moyenne
quand on a fait le tour de tous les
recours c'est plutôt de trois ans et pas
de trois jours or justement pendant ce
temps là les gens ont une vie ont des
enfants ont besoin de manger comme vous
disiez ont besoin d'avoir accès à la
santé d'avoir les vaccins pour leurs
enfants pour qu'ils puissent aller à
l'école des choses très basiques en fait
normal justement quel est le parcours
type d'un réfugié politique en france
une fois qu'il a mis les pieds sur le
territoire national le parc ou de
réfugié politique qui allait veut en
france c'est de chercher à bénéficier
des dispositions de la convention de
genève
comment ceci n'est bien sûr pas l'argent
sinon donc la tva par la france au même
titre que l'ensemble des pays des
nations unies donc qui ont ratifié la
convention la semaine a commencé voici
un condensé a été respectée comment est
appliquée en fonction des pays
le parcours donc et c'est un parcours
sinueux qui de la préfecture où on
dépose donc on dossier de demande
d'asile où on donne donc le document le
fait de remplir ce document et de
l'envoyer à l'ofpra
une fois qu'on a envoyé à l'offre à
l'offre a donc instruit le dossier en
première lecture c'est à dire dans la
première lecture nous le moment l'offre
à convoque le récipiendaire pour voir
effectivement apporter des éclairages
par pendant son parcours les raisons ou
les motivations qui l'ont poussé à
demander donc l'asile en france
en gros pour vérifier s'il est vraiment
un événement donc donc pas se réfugier
peut-être une composante réputée très
motivés sans pour autant que le puits
soit en guerre parce que dans une
dictature
donc les gens pour des raisons de
l'absence de liberté d'opinion ou de
contraintes liées à la la la liberté de
parole ou de l'exercice de
de telles missions citoyennes sont
contraints de quitter dans le pays pour
le sauver leur vie donc c'est là aussi
qu'il faudra faire attention
sous cette dimension de 4 carats
caricaturer ce qui est réfugié qui ne
l'est pas c'est quoi le réfugié ou kaki
qu'est ce qui n'est pas réfugié donc à
partir une fois que l'offre à as ou le
dossier l'ofpra que valider donc la la
la la la première demande
dans ce cas là il obtiendra une optique
écologique le tir de cette fusée
politique il retourne à la préfecture
qui effectivement dû délivre donc au
titre de séjour et à partir de là donc
il enclenche le processus d'insertion et
de de vie quotidienne affluence alors
comment justifier nous refuse la la
première instance
donc d'accorder ans s'est réfugié
politique il a une capacité de réaliser
de réexamen de son dossier dans le cadre
de cours autour de la cour
administrative de réfugiés qui statue
dans de l'équipe et l'ont donc souvent
c'est là où c'est très long et quand en
attendant comment ils font concrètement
pour pouvoir et pour sanaa ryad il ya
deux éléments soit il bénéficie donc des
dispositifs des cadres donc des centres
d'accueil des réfugiés
donc qui généralement gérées par france
terre d'asile
s'ils ne sont pas hébergés donc par
français d'asile sont généralement ils
sont logés par des amis d'accord ou pas
des associations donc comme le secours
catholique ou le secours populaire qui
donc qu'il est quelqu'un qui les
accueillent un dessin de la compagnie
donc à partir de ce moment là donc si
cette demande au cours de réfugiés aussi
est terminée sa réponse favorable
il a aussi faculté de pouvoir demander
un réexamen de son dossier mais là aussi
ces hypothétiques ça peut tourner en est
sa couleur
alors comment résoudre cette équation
parce que beaucoup de français se posent
cette question hein faut faire des
économies serrer la ceinture de chiffres
du chômage sont en postant
d'augmentation et 3 il ya plus en plus
de pauvres
sarah constat c'est à la partager en
tout cas en france est-ce que malgré
cela la france les yvelines saint
quentin en yvelines pour réduire on les
moyens d'accueillir des réfugiés
quel qu'il soit là ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est les réfugiés
politiques les registres guerre mais
est-ce qu'on a les moyens
qui va payer
je pose pas tout à fait la question
comme ça parce que c'est évidemment il
faut avoir une vision un peu mondial de
ce qui se passait même si les
difficultés lourdes en france et on est
bien placé pour le savoir y compris à la
verrière qui est une commune populaire
avec un taux de chômage important il ya
un des solidarités qui existent et c'est
le fondement de notre humanité à tous et
donc nous avons évidemment nous sommes
portés par ses fondements de l'humanité
donc nous accueillons des gens qui sont
plus pauvres plus en difficulté qui sont
confrontées quand même une question de
vie ou de mort de vie ou de mort c'est
quand même pas tout à fait le cas dans
la situation en france même s'il ya des
difficultés lourd donc la question
domicile fixe bien sûr bien sûr pour
lequel l'action publique devrait
d'ailleurs être bien meilleur et
s'interrogent d'ailleurs la crise et
milan l'action publique sur les publics
pendant que vous parlais justement voit
des images de l'accueil des réfugiés à
bonnel de deuxième élément on parle de
24000 moi moi il ya deux trois choses
qui me choquent et me surprennent je lui
dire franchement 24000 en deux ans
réfugiés accueillis en france 24 milles
c'est moins d'un par commune française
ya 36000 communes en france on vous voit
aussi que la répartition de l'effort
peut-être regarder parce que c'est pas
aux beaucoup je pense que d'ailleurs la
france pourrait faire sans doute mieux
que vingt-quatre mille personnes
accueillies de troisième élément
moi je supporte pas cette cette
classification aujourd'hui entre
réfugiés de guerre réfugiés et que
va-t-on dire demain pour les réfugiés
climatiques
pourquoi ceux qui sont confrontés à la
misère issus de guerre
quelquefois dans lequel nous avons des
responsabilités ne sont plus placés
comme des réfugiés de guerre mais comme
j'ai économique alors qu'ils ont subi
les conséquences de guerre que nous
avons quelquefois provoquer ou bien
d'une famille ou d'une misère dont nous
avons quand même quelque part aussi
quelquefois des responsabilités donc
voilà ça interroge plus généralement nos
rapports nord-sud les rapports de
géopolitique
parce que finalement qu'est ce qu'on
veut on voudrait bien et les gens aussi
j'aimerais bien rester en leur pays
y'a pas un migrant qui a envie de venir
forcément ils ont envie de rester dans
leur pays bas jusqu'au mans du coup
qu'est ce que vous dites à ces mères qui
disent qu'ils ne peuvent pas recevoir
qui n'ont pas les moyens de recevoir
parce que vous pensez que c'est un faux
argument il ya toujours une solution
je pas là pour juger quiconque moi je
pense que nous avons la responsabilité
d' interpeller quand nous avons pas les
moyens
les autorités nationales ou les
autorités départementales dont c'est
aussi la responsabilité pour mobiliser
les moyens
donc la question c'est comment nous
organisons les moyens à la verrière par
exemple il ya des associations qui tout
de suite on dit nous on veut participer
il ya une association qui va aller
dimanche prochain à bonnel préparer un
repas avec d'ailleurs le secours
populaire qui a accepté et des femmes de
la verrière iront donc c'est possible
c'est pour ces possibles bernard demain
alors que répondez-vous à linge âge
c'est possible en tous les cas
oui c'est possible mais le chiffre de 24
mille il faut l'ajouter par rapport à ce
qui arrive en france à ce qui arrive par
d'autres canaux
1 ceux qui rentrent en france de manière
irrégulière et qui se retrouve
finalement dans la même situation
1 il n'y a qu'à regarder toutes les
occupations cas puis avoir par le passé
en différentes occasions de gens qui
aussi se retrouver dans cette situation
même s'ils venaient pas de syrie ou
d'irak c'est possible aussi
et je rejoins tout à fait l'alsace pour
redire
il faut pas concentrer ces gens dans
quelques villes de france où quelques
régions c'est ce qu'il allait revendre à
ses bras sans on a même des régions de
france qui se dépeuple et c'est aussi
possible à la condition c'est que on est
des aides
parce que les associations ne pourrons
pas tout faire pour des choses bassement
mateille je vais prendre l'école de mes
petites irakienne elle arrive en france
leur écriture ces délais tram
elles connaissent même pas notre
alphabet ce qui est beaucoup plus
difficile que ce qu'on a fait par le
passé pour les milliers demi
qui venait par exemple d'espagne après
la guerre d'espagne ou d'italie ou de
pologne ou autre mais déjà l'alphabet ne
connaissent pas la langue
ils n'ont pas deux c'est pas une langue
latine on n'a pas de racines communes
faut tout apprendre et apprendre souvent
ça pour certains enfants qui ont déjà un
certain âge donc donc ça vaut des cours
spécialisés avec des centres spécialisés
donc la demande voilà allez vous pouvoir
les y conduire
donc ça demande de l'aide de l'état
pascale roze et vous dirai oui fin par
rapport à ça vous avez raison de dire
que ça demande des moyens ça demande
énormément de moyens humains ça demande
du temps je crois qu'après aussi sur
certaines enfin moi je savais que dans
mon héritage familial il ya des gens qui
ont des parcours de migration et où un
enfant de 5 6 ans pour l'apprentissage
du français ça va plus vite que quand on
a 50 ou 60 ans donc c'est vrai que ça
prend du temps mais en même temps
souvent par les enfants c'est par les
enfants par nous on a souvent dans nos
accueils dans nos accueille les enfants
qui font interprète pour le compte de
leurs parents les yeux d'ailleurs est ce
que c'est vraiment le rôle des enfants
on peut s'interroger là dessus mais en
tout cas ils le font parce que c'est la
vie qui est comme ça et donc souvent les
parents reconnaissent les logos des
institutions et puis après c'est les
enfants qui traduisent un petit peu ce
qu'il ya ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il
faut amener à coup on a le droit etc et
vous avez des enfants des fois dix ans
qui sont des médiateurs pour l'heure
leur famille complète donc je voulais
dire juste dire que effectivement dans
le cadre de la réforme du ceseda donc le
le code d'accès du thé sur les ailes
enfin le code le code des étrangers les
conditions de séjour et des länder
d'asile c'est une problématique dans le
cadre de la consultation des
associations tout cas c'est nous ce que
nous avons relayé qu'effectivement c'est
là où ça rejoint l'action politique
d'aidé mer
les élus locaux si vous emboliser des
territoires avec en multipliant les
difficultés économiques d'intégration et
d'apprentissage bien dur et ça crée des
inégalités de territoire pour tout le
monde et ça va être dur pour tout le
monde donc on le lit sans peut-être que
ça facilitera le modem il ya une
véritable bataille politique qui se
faire sur ce thème des réfugiés on va
regarder ce qu'a dit et valérie pécresse
justement sur cette question mais elle a
tout simplement peur elles se demandent
solennellement elle demande au premier
ministre de faire effectuer sans délai
par les forces de sécurité tous les
contrôles et croisements de fichiers
nécessaires pour s'assurer qu'aucune des
personnes accueillies ne soient d'ores
et déjà enregistrés par nos services
comme ayant un lien avec une activité
terroriste
on prendra que peut-être que dans ces
réfugiés qui arrivent se cache
voilà des suppôts de dèche je crois que
ça que c'est une parole politicienne
qui est un peu le tennis et il n'ya pas
les régionales il ya les régionales qui
ne sont pas loi comme en décembre et que
c'est à cause de ça qu'il suffit cette
parole là par rapport à un certain
électorat par rapport à certains
discours politiques
je crois que darche n'a pas besoin de
faire venir des dialyses en france ils
les prennent en france et des années
donc le problème n'est pas là donc je
crois que autant qu'à gauche à droite
l'essentiel c'est d'éviter
d'instrumentaliser à des fins
politiciennes de gestion de carrière
politique qui est importante et
vis-à-vis de laquelle la france a un
devoir en devoir en tant que puissance
en devoir contrer des obligations
internationales de la france continue
aussi de ce gala de la signature de la
france au titre de la convention de
genève mais aussi que iliad est en
tournée pour être honnête
voilà et que parler du principe de
solidarité nous avons des raisons et
même d'au-delà de la convention de
genève il ya les directives européennes
en matière d'accueil des étrangers
mais pour ne pas subir leurs foudres de
la directive des directives européennes
en matière d'accueil des étrangers
les états ont demandé l'application de
la subsidiarité à respecter la devise la
socialité c'est la possibilité pour
l'état de d'appliquer sa législation
nationale ou leigh d'appliquer la
législation européenne en la matière ce
qui fait que tous les pays européens
aujourd'hui les difficultés qu'on a dans
le partage des quotas en matière
d'accueil de réfugiés est liée à cette
double à cette politique à cette
problématique politique qui est que les
états non seulement contre nous la
directive européenne en matière
d'accueil de fedasil
mais aujourd'hui préfèrent pratiquer
leurs propres législations nationales en
matière d'immigration et on sait que
l'application des politiques nationales
en matière d'immigration sont souvent
soumis à des contextes politiques locaux
acquis qui sont très compliquées et qui
empêche donc une certaine vérité
politique par rapport à par rapport à
l'électorat ou sa peur de froisser
l'électorat c'est à dire que l'on désire
porter pour l'édification de une
certaine forme et j'ai sur le canal
politique donc
l'explication demande à mme pécresse va
dans ce sens là c'est une gestion
électoralistes pendant donc à justifier
un comportement politique comme moi je
ne partage pas parce que bernard de vent
est en train de faire donner de la tête
il avait là il a la liberté de contester
obligé dit non mais vous dire pourquoi
soir a dit un bémol
valérie pécresse s'est rendue en irak
l'année dernière et c'est à son retour
d'irak où elle avait été avec trois
quatre parlementaires qu'elle avait
lancé un appel pour accueillir des
réfugiés iraquiens donc à la chanson
gagnante le temps pas lui faire ce genre
de procès réfugiés s'ils étaient
chrétiens en trop parce qu'à l'époque
c'était eux qui étaient massacrés pour
leur religion étaient postés là entre la
première va et les chrétiens d'irak
donc il prévenu la france je crois que
c'est normal compte tenu des traditions
chrétiennes en france la solidarité
religieuse donc importante mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la situation des réfugiés
politiques dépassent largement cette
notion de solidarité
il s'est demandé en france un étranger
combien de contrôles il a dans le mois
par les forces de police pour savoir
quand même que c'est pas la question du
contrôle le contrôle a lieu et les faits
donc c'est pas ça usage de la phrase
effectivement est une phrase qui me fait
peur parce qu'aujourd'hui
allez voir sur internet ce qui se dit
sur les migrants et les réfugiés c'est
terrible on est en train de réveiller ce
qui a de plus moche de ce qui est plus
dur chez les gens alors qu'en réalité on
pourrait éveiller ce qui est meilleur
c'est à dire le sentiment d'humanité et
donc faut qu'on soit attentif à ce qu'on
dit chaque phrase pèse dans le débat
aujourd'hui est profondément les
français comme les allemands d'ailleurs
comme d'autres quand on a envie de leur
parler laurent leur parler d'un langage
de vérité
ils ont l'humanité qui se réveille parce
que c'est pas possible de rester
insensible à ce qui se passe donc la
responsabilité d'un homme ou d'une femme
politique c'est effectivement de ne pas
contextualiser avec les élections qui
vont arriver il c'est de prendre
d'interpeller ça c'est normal
d'interpeller effectivement les pouvoirs
publics sur les conditions d'accueil sur
les moyens qui vont être déployés sur la
manière dont vont être accueillis les
réfugiés et des puits après chacun prend
ses responsabilités politiques
moi pour ce qui me concerne
effectivement je considère que c'est la
question
ranque est ouvert et pas simplement la
question des réfugiés dont vous allez en
accueillir oublie pas la verrière alors
commencé son exposé pour écouter nous ne
somme proposée puisque nous étions à la
réunion des maires samedi matin à
méditer par le premier ministre une mise
de l'intérieur donc on nous sommes
proposées nous remplissons un dossier
est ensuite avec les autorités
préfectorales et avec les associations
nous au regard donc est ce que nous
pouvons faire nous pouvons évidemment
mettre à disposition soit deschamps de
temporaire dans des établissements donc
en lien avec nos bailleurs adoma par
exemple mais d'autres nous pouvons
regarder parce que c'est ce étonnant
d'ailleurs on vous l'avait dit à l'heure
mais on s'aperçoit au moment des crises
qu'il existe des logements vides
mais on le sait ça qu'il ya des
logements vides il suffit de regarder à
paris combien de logements solides
est-ce qu'on se rend compte de l'impact
peut-être de ce que vous venez de dire
sur allez on va utiliser le thème de le
terme de france et voilà les français de
base des français de souche si on veut
les appeler forcément vous tord ou des
habitants qui attendent un logement à
l'hôtel q quel est l'impact de dire que
justement camps des réfugiés arrivent on
arrive à trouver des logements mais
quand c'est les autres il n'y a pas de
la phase aller il faut expliquer il faut
expliquer il faut dit il faut débattre
moi j'ai rencontré un certain nombre
d'habitants
le week-end dernier on discute avec eux
ils comprennent même ceux qui sont en
attente de logement parce que cela
qu'ils ont sont en attente de logement
ceux qui ont eu récemment un logement
savent combien il a fallu attendre
combien il a fallu deux démarches pour
avoir un logement et ils savent aussi
reconnaît vous savez qu'au bout à la
verrière au bois de l'étang est allé
dans l'autre quartier de la derrière
combien de personnes réfugiés vivent
dans des familles sont accueillis dans
des familles y en a beaucoup
ils deviennent demandeurs de logement
d'ailleurs et nous les enregistrons il a
beaucoup combien sommes-nous auprès de
combien sont obligés d'agir et
d'interpeller les autorités pour des
régularisations de papier autres donc ça
existe des gens profitent justement pour
terminer avec vous à allinges âge une
question twitter on nous demandait ce
que justement d'autres villes là vont
accueillir des réfugiés à saint quentin
en yvelines vous vous l'avez dit la vie
départ votre communiqué de presse de
l'inclure mais est ce que saint quentin
en yvelines va accueillir des réfugiés
quand on entend très peu les autres
maires enfin roland temps de vous pour
l'instant sans cette question n'entend
pas les autres maires dans 50 ans
olivier j'ai interpellé près
de l'agglomération je lui ai dit qu'un
autre échelle ça pouvait tout bonne
échelle de mobilisation des moyens y
compris financiers associatif donc à
l'échelle de l'agglomération nous
pouvons faire un effort toutes les
communes sont pas le type pareil
la verrière est une des communes les
plus populaires les plus en difficulté
nous montrons l'exemple
nous doutons pas que les autres villes
suivront cas la réponse avait obtenu
pour l'instant rien du tout conclut moi
je crois que la question ne se pose pas
dans une démarche est ce que vont dire
les autres lorsqu'on découvre il ya des
logements pour les réfugiés ou les mille
à la question ne se pose pas en ces
termes
la question se pose en termes de
solidarité la question se pose en termes
de devoir vis-à-vis de l'autre le croire
la france doit assumer une
responsabilité politique et l'a donc en
assumant cette responsabilité politique
et là elle donc essayé d'organiser les
moyens allant dans le sens de
l'affirmation de soi sommités politiques
merci en tout cas à tous les cadres
d'avoir participé à ce débat
voilà vraiment de secondes si si les
français n'avaient pas accueilli mon
grand père je ne serais pas là vous non
plus d'ailleurs animé le débat vous
imaginez la perte pour les verrières et
quelles pertes auraient pour 50 ans
intervient
merci en tout cas à tous les pères
d'avoir participé à ce débat
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez réagir
sur le twitter de l'émission hashtag 7,8
société on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau débat et bonne
semaine à tous